bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france le coc vide au
royaume uni la nouvelle vague liés aux
variants omicron mais boris johnson dans
un certain embarras politique avec un
visage qui montent donc celui de prix
tipa tél
oui ben c'est une amie évidemment des
conséquences sanitaires et et des
conséquences économiques et politiques
d'abord
les conséquences sanitaires c'est qu'il
y a depuis le milieu de la semaine
dernière plus de 100000 contamination
par jour au royaume-uni grande bretagne
ce qui est beaucoup les conséquences
politiques se sont manifestés dès le 14
décembre lorsque une centaine de députés
conservateurs ont refusé de voter le
pain sanitaire que le gouvernement
britannique proposait d'instaurer il a
fallu recourir à un apport de députés
travaillistes pour que cette loi soit
votée et puis d'ailleurs
effectivement il ya un certain nombre
d'affaires qui sont accrochés aux
basques de boris johnson
l'une d'entre elles étant la fête qu'il
avait organisé avec ses collaborateurs
aux hôtels d'un look street au mois de
décembre dernier alors que ses
compatriotes étaient confinés et puis il
ya une conséquences politiques graves
qui est la perte d'une circonscription
acquise depuis très longtemps aux
conservateurs nord stroke cher le 15
décembre dernier et ce ne sont pas les
travaillistes d'ailleurs qui ont gagné
très curieusement ce sont les libéraux
démocrates qui sont d'ailleurs des
partisans de l'appartenance à l'union
européenne donc c'est peut-être une
double défaite politique pour boris
johnson sur ce sujet la perte de cette
circonscription et les critiques m'ont
évidemment à l'intérieur du parti
conservateur et comme vous j'ai dit tout
à l'heure et bien des candidatures se
manifeste et notamment celle de la
ministre de l'intérieur principaux tels
principes at elle n'est pas la seule à
pouvoir espérer c'est le poste du
premier ministre
[Musique]
non elle n'est pas la seule mais là elle
a des qualités au dernier congrès du
parti conservateur elle s'est
positionnée sur les dépôts les positions
de madame thatcher c'est à dire des
positions dures
elles considèrent que le parti
conservateur doit avoir des positions
dures sur la plupart des sujets y
compris
l'immigration bien sûr dont elle a la
charge en tant que ministre de
l'intérieur cela dit elle est née en
grande-bretagne bien sûr mais ses
parents sont originaires du gujarat en
inde avait émigré à l'eau en ouganda ont
émigré ensuite en grande bretagne
lorsque amin dada commencé à persécuter
les étrangers et notamment les indiens
alors il ya d'autres candidats il ya
notamment la ministre des affaires
étrangères madame grès qui depuis la
démission du ministre chargé du rexy tu
as aussi en charge les suites du break
site ce qui n'est pas une mince affaire
c'est peut-être un cadeau empoisonné que
lui a fait d'ailleurs boris johnson
sachant qu'elle souhaitait aussi être
candidate à sa succession
mais c'est une militante conservatrice
qui a aussi ses partisans et puis il y
en a un troisième qui est le sens il
était chic et donc le ministre des
finances
qui
est un très brillant
personnages dont les parents sont
également originaires d'inde qui a fait
des études en grande-bretagne et aux
etats-unis et qui est probablement le
plus le plus brillant sur le plan
intellectuel maintenant il va falloir
que le parti conservateur choisissent
choisissent quel est celui qui plaira le
plus aux électeurs et il est bien
possible que ce soit l'une des deux
candidates
que ce soit le tour d'une femme à
nouveau d'être premier ministre de
grande bretagne
donc si j'avais à parier je parierais
plutôt pour prix tipa tél et pour lise
stress en tout cas que deux branches
maison avec ce que vous nous dites on a
bien l'impression que le remplaçant de
boris johnson est tout proche
alors oui mais nous sommes nombreux tags
et tout est différent en grande bretagne
en effet boris johnson a montré qu'il
pouvait aussi être très résilient et
qu'il a une grande capacité à faire des
gaffes mais aussi à se sortir de
situations très difficiles et souvent
avec ce qui fait la force des public
school britannique c'est à dire en
prenant les gens un peu un peu à la fois
de haut et en plaisantant avec les gens
autrement dit en lui prenant à l'estomac
c'est un plus qui l'a fait avec toute sa
campagne sur le break site qui l'a amené
au thème d'amestris donc pour le moment
il n'a pas dit son dernier mot et il
faut attendre que la période des fêtes
passe en grande-bretagne pour savoir
comment le parti conservateur va
résoudre cet épineux problème il a une
majorité très importante aux communes
dont il n'y a pas une absolue urgence à
remplacer le premier ministre même si en
effet il a beaucoup de casseroles à ses
basques merci beaucoup cld blanchemaison
pour toutes ces précisions je rappelle
que vous êtes expert en relations
internationales